tom brady continues to be the crown
jewel of the 2020 free agency class
whenever free agency begins and it's
technically supposed to begin in six
days as a practical matter it starts on
monday when the window opens for making
offers to guys who will become free
agents and chris we've been identifying
a small handful of teams
the patriots obviously the titans the
49ers yesterday came the report from
rick stroud out of the tampa bay times
that the
tampa bay buccaneers going all in to
sign tom brady with bruce arians leading
the charge oh my gosh to be a fly on the
wall for the first meeting between bruce
arians and tom brady but aryans has a
reputation for working very well with
quarterbacks his book from a few years
ago was called the quarterback whisperer
and you know i i could see
brady viewing bruce aryans as a not a
breath of fresh air he's a full oxygen
tank he's one of those oxygen trucks you
see on the highway of fresh air after
dealing with doom and gloom for 20 years
so uh look i'm root for chaos you know
that yep as it relates to football uh
and uh i want to see
the world turned upside down as it
relates to football uh and i want tom
brady to be on a new team and all of a
sudden i'm smitten by the idea of tom
brady going to the buccaneers and being
with one of our favorite coaches bruce
eric well that's right i mean we got
another team to talk about here you know
the more and i know this was reported
yesterday but the more and more we go
here the more i've heard too that the
tennessee titans will not be in the
brady conversation so then that leads me
to believe that it's the 49ers the
patriots and maybe now the tampa bay
buccaneers you know one thing i can say
for sure the glazer family who owns the
buccaneers great family they've been
looking for this type of guy
to be the quarterback of their franchise
really ever since they've taken over you
know hey they hoped it would work for me
you know when i got hurt they were in we
were in the brett favre sweepstakes
right you know they've drafted of course
some guys very high in the draft to
hopefully be that franchise guy they
flirted with this so i understand them
loving a guy like tom brady jason light
who's down there he came from new
england was working in the front office
and then other thing i think about mike
too is like we hear about brady not
being appreciated right you know that's
this to your point like he'll he'll
bruce aries is going to appreciate him
and one thing you hear about bruce
arians with his quarterbacks is he can
get them to like eat out of his hands
because he is so in the fight with them
all the time you know and makes them
feel like hey it's you and me wait right
unless unless you throw 30 interceptions
well then hey that then he goes hey
actually there's no more food left in my
hand and i have to say i have to see if
somebody else out here is willing to eat
from it you're right there's an issue
there now the other thing i'll say about
it too is
i don't know if i see tom brady going
down to tampa bay and living there and
living that life all right i'm just
gonna say that i loved it i'm not saying
anything personal i'm just saying this
is tom brady this is superstar hollywood
and giselle bundchen this they're a
different class of persons hey
i got it right
stop the show
oh my gosh he got it out in two
syllables i got it out in two syllables
no but it was it was worth the the break
there but you know the other thing i'll
say just from the negative aspect i
think about a little bit football wise
with this one is bruce arians is famous
for getting his quarterbacks beat up and
telling them to hold the ball and
hey just no no biscuit no no risk it no
biscuit right you know that's the saying
that goes with him because it means he
wants you to be aggressive throw the
ball down the field stand in the pocket
take shots remember jameis winston put
on 20 pounds last year because bruce
aryan says you're gonna hold on the ball
we're gonna throw it down the field is
brady gonna be willing to do that type
of thing at this point of his career to
me that's one of the biggest negatives
of this game right now so that's what
will be interesting to me as well
and the other thing to keep in mind to
the extent that the nfl orders the
off-season calendar to accommodate
coronavirus and you have less time to
work with your new team last time on the
practice field that becomes a factor in
how attractive this offer may be to tom
brady but the buccaneers are in it and
maybe they will win it now um
other teams who knows as you said the
titans it just feels like it's a
leverage play on ryan tannehill yeah and
there were some who suggested that
that's the theory and i guess that makes
sense that you you flirt with tom brady
just enough to get ryan tannehill to
take the offer that's on the table and i
agree with you i think
i think they're
i think i think they're better off with
ryan tannehill than tom brady i just
hesitate because i know you know the
minute the minute that we all join the
ryan tannehill fan club is the minute he
tears his acl again that's what i'm
concerned about i i hear you i mean
that's that's legit i mean you're not
wrong in thinking that and worrying
about that that's got to be part of the
thing that the john robinson and mike
frable have to you know balance in their
own mind as well and hopefully able to
balance that in the contract but yeah i
certainly would take tannehill right now
over brady i understand that and you
know of course tana hill still he's just
hitting the prime of his career to where
he's going to give you hope as an
organization if you saw the things you
liked over this last year that go man we
can build around this guy this is pretty
good so yeah for me i really look at it
and go
just all the signs point to either it's
49ers or patriots and again i'm gonna
state this one more time during the for
the week i mean
adam schefter
is very connected to brady
and the shanahan family
adam schefter was a guy who
texted or tweeted and made comments
during the nfl season pretty much
predicting everything we've seen between
brady and the patriots back in october
he was sending out tweets and people
thought oh he's kind of crazy that'll
never happen but he he was spot on if
you go back and look at what he said and
tweeted so then you have that and he's
gone dark it's the biggest story in the
nfl to me that just says it all that he
knows this is real he can't tweet about
it because he's been told by both sides
so he's kind of handcuffed that way and
i think that's the biggest clue we got
going right now let alone we haven't had
a guy like brady or the 49ers shoot it
down i don't think we need to hear that
it's really real it's real we just it's
real it's by what's not being said to us
that we know it's real
yeah it's real and here's the thing if
it doesn't happen people will say it was
never real it it's real yeah it's real
right it's it's you know just i mean
that that and and i i i you know tw
twitter twitter is its own creature at
times and trying to reason with twitter
is in many ways it's hard and trying to
teach a dog how to drive a car right but
but uh yeah it just be just because it
doesn't happen if it doesn't happen
doesn't mean it wasn't real is it real
in las vegas with the raiders and tom
brady john gruden was asked recently
about tom brady and his response you're
killing me man well he can't talk about
tom brady he can't say that i want tom
brady i'm interested in tom brady
although bruce arians did that a couple
of weeks ago and he's yet to be charged
with tampering but gruden said we love
our quarterback our quarterback's a
really good player derek carr i want to
reiterate that to everybody here in
vegas we've got a good young quarterback
and the film the statistics and
analytics prove it well that may be news
to mike mayok the gm of the team isn't
bashful about saying we're always
looking to upgrade at every position
including quarterback but it sure feels
like brady's not in the cards for the
raiders chris you and i seem to agree
that there would be a lot more reporting
linking the raiders to brady because
john gruden would be talking to people
about it trying to make sure that he's
doing the right thing by bringing in a
quarterback who's about to be 43. i it's
very possible that brady has made it
clear to the raiders you're not
interested in las vegas and that ended
that right i think that would probably
be my guess if that ended that would be
what you said there at the end you know
because i just think again
brady as much as he might have been like
oh the raiders in vegas and john gruden
and that could be cool
you know you know as much as i expect
the raiders to be an improved football
team this year and better and a player
and free agency here at all that i don't
i'm not putting them in the super bowl
contender category and again i just
don't think tom brady at 43 is gonna
waste a year to go okay guys let's build
something so when i'm 44 we can make the
run i just don't see that being a
logical thought and a smart guy like tom
brady's head so yeah i think that's out
the door i think the raiders know that
and that's why now they're trying to go
back into almost a damage control to say
oh derek carr is great you love them
even though they've like you know that's
not what they always say and give us the
sign warning signs for it i mean it's
natural for us to question it right i
mean that's where i don't understand the
raiders sometimes you you you flirted
with quarterbacks in the draft last year
you're the one that has opened this door
of this conversation of whether derek
carr should be the guy or not not us
and you know i'm i like derek carr i
think he's good uh he needs some help
and we'll see where that goes this year
and here's the other thing too chris if
tom brady's going to go to the afc west
and deal with patrick that's right mike
twice per year go to the chargers not
the raiders yeah right right they're a
team that's like
you got a better chance to win with all
due respect to the raiders sorry raiders
fans
you go to the chargers you got a better
chance to win than if you go to the
raiders i think so i mean the chargers
at least have a defense where you'd be
able to look at them right away and go
hey i got evidence that they've given my
homes and company you know a lot of crap
they've given them a tough time they you
know and of course they got bosa and
ingram coming off the edge derwyn james
i mean they got some studs yes you know
but ultimately i think what
your point about the afc west i think is
real too you know who the hell would
want to deal with that right now and
mahomes and andy reid and then yeah
that's just scary to me let alone the
chargers have been one of the worst
offensive lines in football the last few
years and i don't think brady's going to
want to deal with that either and get
you know lamb basted while they try to
figure out how to get the best five
offensive linemen out there on the field
so do you still think that he stays the
patriots
i do i do i really am like but it's like
5149 where i probably would have said
like at 60 40. wow but i feel like with
the fact that we have heard nothing from
the 49ers and continue to hear rumors
about it
and nothing else there i just think it's
i i haven't i just think it's going to
be close i do i really do i just don't
know where where it's going to go i mean
you know to me is where's brady yet does
brady want to stay
uh is he using this as a leverage play
or does he really kind of just want to
go no screw you new england and
belichick and i haven't been appreciated
i want to go somewhere new you know what
is it is it going to be a call the 49ers
saying we want you and then it's going
to happen or is it brady's call i just i
don't know that and that would be really
interesting to to know that
i'm telling you a new factor in all of
this that tom brady may not have even
realized yet but i think he will
the extent to which coronavirus
potentially impacts and limits the
off-season training program
that may make leaving the patriots less
attractive because it will minimize his
opportunities to get himself ready with
a new team we haven't seen him at otas
much in recent years but he knows that
system like the back of his hand going
to a new place i think there's going to
be a premium on getting yourself
properly in sconce with the coaching
staff with your teammates with the city
with the facility with everything and if
we see that shrunken in any way shape or
form that becomes a factor for tom brady
i agree how that plays out and we'll see
a free agency plays out next week
hi i'm mike tarico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from nbc
sports